-Giancarlo welcome to the show.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
I have so many questions
to ask you.
I have so many things
that I'm a fan of yours.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I'm honored to have you here.
I want to start off by saying --
"Mandalorian," we want it back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're fantastic in it.
It is back in March.
Finally, it's coming.
-"You have something I want."
-Aah! That's exactly --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you know what?
I gotta tell you,
thank you so much
for having me on the show.
I'm honored to be here.
You are the king.
I've wanted to be here
for many years.
And finally, you invited me!
-Oh, yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
Come on, bud.
-"Mandalorian" is a great show.
I really love doing that show.
-But you know how to do it.
You know how to create
a character and make it
a legendary character.
Here you are, though, acting
opposite a very cute puppet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I gotta tell you, I will squash
that little big-eared bastard.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's exactly right!
Yes.
-Look, I walk by that puppet --
Jon Favreau,
who called me and said,
"Do you want to be
a part this show?"
He said, "I have good news,
I have bad news."
I said, "Well,
tell me the good news first."
"The good news is,
I wrote a role for you
of Moff Gideon,
in 'Mandalorian.'"
I said, "What's that?"
He said, "it's a 'Star Wars.'
It's a new 'Star Wars' show
that I'm doing."
I said, "Okay, great.
What's the bad news?"
"The bad news is that all the
money is going into the Volume."
And he started
talking technically
and talking about the story
and all these good things.
And I said to him, "Jon, I want
to work with people I like.
That's the bottom line."
I did not want to say --
came very close to saying --
"I would do it for free."
[ Laughter ]
No, you don't to say that.
-No, but you loved it that much.
-I loved it that much.
And he said,
"Are there any requests?"
I said, "I have one request.
Please, I must have a cape."
And he said, "Done deal!"
-Wow!
-And that --
-That was you.
-It was me.
It sold me on everything
that I could have a cape.
Because, you know,
this show allowed me to feel
like a kid again.
You know?
It made me dream again.
It made me be in wonder again.
It made me feel like I could
go any place in the universe,
and carry my dreams,
my hopes,
and my imagination with me.
-Wow. I kind of feel
that way watching it.
That's a great way
of putting it.
Really.
It really is one of the most
creative shows to watch that.
And to actually watch
Grogu come to life.
What did you call it
before it had a name?
-Well, it was called The Child
for a long time.
And it was sitting on a desk.
And I'd walk by,
and Jon and I were chatting --
I think he's a genius.
He's written
such a beautiful show.
David Filoni, his partner,
is also fantastic.
This comes out of a relationship
with George Lucas
and Joseph Campbell.
So, what we love about the show,
you may not know, is that
it's the power of the mythology
of the show
that you can see your hero and
your heroine within Mando.
And we walk by a table,
and he said, "Hey,"
just casually, "You want to take
a look at The Child?"
I said, "Certainly."
And he pulls the canvas off.
And I looked at
this practical child.
And he explained to me
it was gonna be this,
it was going to be that -- CGI.
I said, "No, this perfect."
And then the puppeteer walked by
at that very moment.
And the puppeteer said, "Do you
want to see and talk to him?"
[ Laughter ]
I went, "Okay."
And The Child opened its eyes,
turned its head,
wiggled its ears.
And I was -- you can't take your
eyes off of this child.
Grogu is fascinating,
mysterious, intelligent, smart.
And I looked at Jon, and I said,
"Jon --"
I said, "Jon,
this is the star of the show."
And he stood back,
and he scratched his chin,
and he said, "You think so?"
I said, "I know so.
And every scene that I'm in
has to be with this child."
[ Laughter ]
Put it in the contract, baby!
-Exactly.
And you crush it.
But then, everyone loves you.
We love your character,
even though you're the villain.
But just -- also, online,
a lot of fans want you to be
in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
-I love what Marvel does.
I love that the fans can see me
in this universe
and are proposing not only
one character, possibly Magneto,
possibly freeze.
And the biggest ask
is Charles Xavier.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, look,
I want to play a good guy.
And Charles is smart.
He's good.
But I feel as if there may be
some mileage with me and Marvel.
I know I love what they do.
I know I love creativity.
So, who knows what could happen.
Keep putting it out there.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The fans love you.
I heard a rumor, and
tell me if this is true or not.
That you may or may not have
something to do with
Barack and Michelle Obama's
relationship.
-Oh, my goodness.
So, I love what Barack Obama
has done and continues to do
to forward the human spirit
and also to exemplify someone
who has a wonderful morality
and who is in service.
I believe that to be in service
is our best bet
for our own life.
So, I was at
the Democratic convention.
And I was standing
about from here to the monitor
from Barack
when he made his speech.
And I was so very impressed.
I was with Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
We walked out.
He said,
"I'm gonna get the car."
And I said,
"Okay, I'll wait for you."
And I'm walking,
and I hear, "Yo!"
And I'm like,
"Who is yo'ing me?"
-You're like,
"Sylvester Stallone is here."
-You know what I mean?
I'm not in the neighborhood.
-Yeah.
-You know, "Yo!" again.
And I turn,
and I see these two gentlemen.
And as they start
coming towards me,
I realize one is Barack Obama.
I'm like,
"Well, you've to be kidding me."
He's like, "I just gotta talk
to you, I gotta talk to you.
'Do the Right Thing'
is one of my favorite movies."
Tells me a whole story about how
he bought Michelle ice cream
and how they went to see
"Do the Right Thing"
for their very first date.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so, I saw the future.
And I saw that he was just
a beautiful human being
and knew who he'd be.
I finally got a chance
to tell him,
"You're gonna be
the president of
the United States one day.
Just stay the course."
-You said that to him?
-Of course I did.
-Yeah, of course you did.
That's exactly the way to do it.
That's exactly right.
You knew it!
-I knew it!
-I want to talk about this
new series, "Kaleidoscope."
Before we can get into
what it's about,
I like the idea that's on top
of the idea, that --
and tell me if
I've got this correct.
Every Netflix account
is set up differently.
Some have different algorithms
or whatever that.
So when I watch "Kaleidoscope,"
I will start
at a different episode than
if you watch "Kaleidoscope."
It's just -- the episodes
are all different.
-Correct.
Correct.
One of the fascinating things
about "Kaleidoscope,"
which I'm very, very proud of,
is that the delivery system
is that you can choose
how you watch it,
which means you're choosing
how the story unfolds.
There are no numbers --
one, two, three, four, five.
There are only colors -- orange,
blue, green, yellow, white.
It is violet.
And so, it's fascinating.
It's a kaleidoscope of color,
thus the title that ties us in,
but the most wonderful thing
is that the story is connected
via character and event.
One event
surrounds all eight episodes.
You should watch white last,
I suggest.
And it spans 25 years.
And I play a character named
Ray Vernon in the beginning,
who is a master thief.
And if I told you
how I prepared for this role,
you'd be excited, too.
Mm.
So, I play this master thief,
who gives up one life,
gives up one identity,
and becomes another
through circumstance
and events of the show.
What really drew me to the show,
was that you, as an audience,
I, as an audience,
would have a choice
as to how I wanted
to see it happen.
And there are all these
Easter eggs and clues
throughout all
that connect every story.
So, you can see
one complete heist.
It's about a heist that
took place during a hurricane
back in the late '70s,
early '80s,
of $70 billion
in unsecured bearer bonds.
And because of
this particular heist
that happened in history --
we're loosely based on that --
the U.S. government
changed the law.
There can be
no more unsecured bonds.
So, since then,
all bonds have to be registered
so you can't use them
for illicit means,
i.e, buying arms or drugs
or jewelry.
So, this particular heist
is an exciting one.
But it's more exciting
because it pits a ne'er-do-well
group of thieves
against a large industry,
a private firm, that will hold
your money and your jewelry.
And it's also a revenge story.
It's a fabulous piece.
I had a chance
to really excel in,
physically and also mentally,
my preparation.
I was in an airport,
and I thought to myself,
"I'm gonna play a thief.
How do I sneak --"
No, come on, no kidding!
How do I sneak up on somebody
stealthily -- be behind them
without them knowing."
This really happened.
I'll tell you the truth
about me.
I am a bad man.
[ Laughter ]
So, I sneak up on a lady.
She's walking.
And everyone's
on their cellphone.
No one's paying attention
anymore anyway.
And she had a pen
in her coat pocket.
And her coat was open, and
it was flapping a little bit,
and I thought,
"Let's see how good I am.
If I can just get to that pen
with two fingers..."
And so I snuck up on her.
I was over her right shoulder,
and I trailed her.
And I got my fingers
in her pocket,
very much
like this patch pocket.
And I took the pen,
and I slid it up,
and then I dropped it
on the ground.
-Yes.
-I didn't want to steal it.
-No, point proven.
-Point proven! I did it!
-Point made! I can do this!
-And you know what I did?
-What?
Oh, wait.
I think I know what you did.
-I made the "Malcolm X" move.
What did I do?
Tell me what I did.
-You told her, "Excuse me, miss,
you dropped your pen."
-That's right, baby!
-That's exactly --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly --
Come on, bud.
-I was so proud of myself!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, man.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Giancarlo Esposito
in "Kaleidoscope."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Metal clatter ]
-♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
-No one can pinpoint the exact
moment it all fell apart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Giancarlo Esposito!
"Kaleidoscope" is streaming now
on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with a performance from Alvvays.
Stick around, everybody.